the world number two player fabiano
caruana fabi we felt like you were in
deep trouble in this game
at some point what was your perception
coming right out of the opening here
yeah something went wrong um
probably knight b3 is not the right way
i should i guess take on c6 or something
but i i didn't i underestimated his
counter play here
um or also queen d2 i guess i can castle
fish buffet 92 it's
this second i
yeah
we'll bring this up where is the game
i'm trying to sorry
where is it where's pappy's game it's
the last one the last one yes at the
very bottom
ah because it's a result
of course
sorry fabi you played knight c3 first of
all this was a novelty
yeah i think the position is pretty rare
no matter what uh either of us play but
yeah we're both in in new territory
knight b3 i thought that it would leave
his pieces cramped but somehow he i'm a
bit underdeveloped
and if i'm able to consolidate
but castle yeah i should castle bishop
of 892 and
i'm not better but i doubt i'm worse
either
castles bishop f8 knight d2
you grew you regretted not going in this
direction yeah i still
was kind of playing ambitiously
but i'm really leaving my king in the
center yeah the problem is a3 he has a5
it starts to get very
um
i mean i can play bishop b5
but he has so many options with
compensation
um and a strong initiative so
what did you see here bishop's hb5
what's his next move well okay he can
play a4 i have to drop back to c1 with
tonight
uh and i thought at the very least rook
b8 is playable
um but it was just like hold on
show the folks and myself bishop takes
a4 is not good because
um no not on this move in the previous
oh bishop 49e4 looked very good for
black
maybe even rook a4 first but i had at
least this um the point being let's show
the line please knight takes
rook takes and now the knight hanging
can't leave because of
the threat along the e line yeah i think
this is pretty much resigns my king is
still in the center unfortunately
it never castled which is a bit of an
issue
um yeah anyway this stuff didn't appeal
to me although maybe it was better than
f3 i mean maybe i can play a3 a5 f3 or i
have some other options
but yeah f3
i mean this whole line
was based on a blunder
which was um
i thought that after bishop f6
i mean when i played f3 i was looking at
dc bishop b2 short castle
and
forgot about bishop c1 it looks a bit
stupid now but this
was kind of a blind spot when i played
f3
i thought that i would get two pieces
for the rook and uh and it should be
pretty decent for white but bishop c1 he
he gets the piece
back um
directly
yeah with a big advantage i i even get a
pawn back but my king remains weak
because of f4
the f4 pawn is
is too far advanced
but i thought that my position later was
totally fine like something went
i don't know
like after c4 maybe he shouldn't take
because now i i don't feel like i'm i
take knight takes take take i don't feel
like i'm any worse now
um
so even after going upon down no i mean
here i should have
like if i trade all the rooks i'm
actually a bit better i think
um
the
problem is i didn't see a clear way to
do it maybe taken rookie one is the best
way
and now if we're c4 g4
um
97 queen e2 wins a piece
but he has an id4 and i think that's a
draw but okay i guess i shouldn't be
hoping for more
um
knight d4 is a draw by by perpetual
bishop d4 queen g4 and wherever my king
goes he has checks
uh so
so yeah okay
i should have done this of course
uh i thought g3 was clever because i
i thought rook c4 would be
the thing is i i overlooked f6
um
so i thought that this would be very
double edged
but after f6
his king is totally safe on f7 there's
nothing
and it's borderline losing i guess
uh
yeah i was just trying to find a way to
trade the dnc phones at this point you
know which
is sad but
it's the best i have
did he miss something fabi because it
really feels like you're just on the
edge you're just holding on here i was
wondering maybe not rook a5 maybe queen
c8
then he forces my rook to a7 and i
wasn't sure if
it's a better version
um
or if it's exactly the same
now he has
access to the a8 square but like rook a5
queen c3 rook d5 rook c7
he has like rook d1 and queen a8 um
so maybe this was uh
this would have been a serious problem
because now if i trade queens i lose my
a pawns well
and king h3 can't be very good
so yeah i think there
he was a bit low on time but he went for
the most direct option which
didn't work out too well
oops sorry uh
yeah
he played rook a5 in the game and you
think maybe queen c8 he missed he missed
a chance i mean okay queen b5 is
probably a mistake i guess queen e6
it's a simple move and
uh black is up a pawn
it's i think it's 50 50. now if white
draws or or black wins this one and
after queen to c4 d5 right or
queen
yeah queen c4 now doesn't make much
sense
um
so yeah this this was a better option
queen b5 queens before i already thought
maybe i'm just drawing this one
it's kind of important that like
queen c4 if he plays queen d5 i thought
it's a
logical move to try to get a better
version
then i have take
rook a7 rook a5 and bishop b6
which is already
i guess holding a draw
take bishop d8 rook e3 but okay it
should be a draw
take
rook a6
yeah i'm not sure i would probably
probably take on e7 at this point i
don't want to allow him to keep that
knight
nice bobby uh
you you seem a little disturbed like
something happened in this game
that you mis-evaluated and i know a
strong player like herself doesn't like
to
lose the feel of a position and suddenly
realize like what am i why am i worse
with the white pieces is that the case
well it was a bad game i mean that's
that's clear
uh
there was a bunch of moments when
like i wasn't even under pressure you
know i had plenty of time there were
like unforced errors
um
once i had equalized again and i played
this g3 and
uh
that was that was a big mistake and the
opening of course a number of moves were
very questionable
uh
and just generally keeping my kingdom
center it looks like bad feeling
um so yeah it wasn't a good game overall
i don't impress the point but
as a player do you just shake this off
and say it was just a bad game or do you
feel like there's something to fix
no i mean sometimes you have bad games
it's
it's good when you don't lose them
i mean the result is
you know it can
a draw can happen in any game
a loss of white is really upsetting
but a draw you know the result itself is
not a disaster
obviously i can't continue to play
like this but uh
but i had a lucky break
all right well let's uh clean things up
and see you tomorrow
thank you fabi